so my name is Kyle keen I am teaching
him a lecture out at MIT working with
Professor w Craig Carter who's a long
time Wolfram advocate and user and
George varna Vitas who's here and we'll
talk during the second half of the talk
oh there is a little web site their code
seal org or weller mit.edu will get you
to information I'll show that at the end
so that you can decide whether or not
you want more information at the end um
there's a website not going to waste
time with that all right outline so big
picture idea is we've made a learning
management system I have taught with
mathematic and notebooks I was taught
with Mathematica notebooks me and
professors emailed back and forth
Mathematica notebooks and that's how I
learned to program and I wanted to make
that a little bit easier now that I'm a
teacher I don't want to have to deal
with all the email attachments so I made
a whole system to do that it makes my
grading workflow a little bit simpler it
makes assessment a little bit more
robust and also kind of simpler on me
and then there's the second half of the
talk is about data collection and
educational research so there's two big
components one is I want to be able to
teach the things that were taught to me
that let me be successful and the other
is I want to research how people learn
while their programming so authoring
process this is an open kind of
publication there's a website that you
can go to right now and sign up and
submit a file and see what it does and
we're hoping to kind of crowd source
content so we right now teach material
science you know there's people who can
teach physics a lot better than I can I
would love for them to publish something
there's people who can't teach finance
all of this Mathematica educational
stuff you know hopefully we'll be able
to get some people to publish more
content on here and the way to use it
let me zoom out to make
alright the way to use it is we all have
Mathematica notebooks that we've written
up that we send to our students if you
don't you should try it it's a very nice
way to teach computational stuff and you
add a little simple text markup so I
want the student to read this section I
want the student to do this as a problem
here's my solution to that problem and
you upload that file onto a website this
is a picture of a website i dare not try
to use the internet this is a screenshot
of the website you go and you upload
your file oh you create a course and you
take the file that's been converted and
put onto the system and you assign it to
a class and then your students can
download a version of that file for them
to do work in pretty simple so far it's
supposed to be simple I don't like
complicated things student goes
downloads the assignment you can have
categories of assignments due dates how
much it's worth it's a full kind of
Mathematica based learning management
system student has a file in Mathematica
for me right now I'm sticking with the
philosophy of a student should be able
to do their work on an airplane and a
student should be able to do their work
on a Raspberry Pi in Africa or India or
you know Kansas wherever somebody wants
to work on a Raspberry Pi and they get
this file that's built so this place
where the oh this is connected not to me
ah alright the place where the teacher
said I want them to read this it's just
like a text book it has interactive
manipulates it has images it has text
that has math has everything a notebook
can have then they get a problem and
problems have some buttons where they
can do some work and then they can
submit their work it gets submitted
locally encrypted and stored in the file
and we'll gather that later and it gets
a timestamp so we know when they submit
their work and then they can see a
solution that you provide it and you can
either have that solution sitting in the
cloud
or if you choose to have it stored
locally it can store locally and release
as soon as the student has submitted
their work so there's different
workflows depending on how you want to
use the system they do their work in
mathematica save the file as if they're
just working in a notebook and then
upload it back on to the website the
website converts that file into a
greater version this is a toy model of
what the greater thing is which is
actually this notebook that I get and I
get to augment and it comes with some
nice little pallets so I can click and
add some comments and say oh yeah good
job I can go through and see all their
work I don't have to look through the
entire notebook and find their work it
kind of strips that out and gives it to
me it makes it easy for me to grade
makes it easy for me to give them
feedback so that's the kind of logistics
I hope that that's a simple concept it's
a website where you upload a file
students go download the file do their
work upload it you get to grade it
upload your grade and then they get to
see their grade so it's kind of fancy
email now is my five minutes of soapbox
now probably less than five minutes I'll
really try not to be on a soapbox but I
do want to talk about kind of how I view
teaching and what i expect for my
students so there's a lot of people
talking about assessment and automated
assessment I don't do that I have
students that care about getting human
feedback and I think that's important so
we don't just have them writing a piece
of code we have them writing a blog or a
computational experiment or a you know
computational narrative or scientific
exploration you can call it all sorts of
thing we have them writing an entire
notebook worth of contents and we then
have peers look at these notebooks we
look at the notebooks we have them sort
of becoming part of a publishing
ecosystem and combining logic scientific
concepts math computation all of
kind of core fundamental things that we
as professionals need to do in order to
convince other people that we understand
what we're talking about and to convince
ourselves that we understand what we're
talking about so yeah we have very
different expectations we don't care if
they can just output a piece of code
that's a nice piece of code we care if
they can this was a student exploring
the concept of a partition function
which is the science thing and usually
this little line of code would be the
answer that you'd get from any other
system right me a thing that calculates
the symbolic partition function they can
do that but this student also
understands what at costco ensemble how
to describe it using an equation
connecting the equation to the
computational stuff so it's important
you know they're talking about the zero
to make sure that this thing is
something from zero to infinity so now
they're connecting real math to actual
computation and representing that in
written form I yes won't get to
sandboxie are so boxy if I do push me
all right um so standard digital
assessment is multiple choice questions
that's fine it's been the thing for a
long time it's supposed to be a proxy
for applied contextual recall in order
to remember and learn something you
should have to recall it a little bit
use it recall it a little bit do
something else recall it a little bit
multiple choice questions do a little
bit of that but it's not so much applied
and that's not really contextual recall
there's short answer you know a way to
do a little bit of natural language
processing to see if the students at the
right keywords or some type of you know
text analysis if you do some automated
code verification you can figure out
that they wrote the right piece of code
I for my students none of those things
are going to verify that they understood
something if they can convince me
through written form that they know how
to apply a concept and a technical
infrastructure to explore a topic then I
feel that they've learned and they feel
that they've learned which is very
important so and even that little
a sample that I showed up there was
really short we usually get these five
page documents on the projects that are
these like beautiful blog ready pieces
of computational science so that's the
learning component of it or this that's
the students learning component of it
this is the teachers learning component
of it so we're collecting a bunch of
data zoom in a little bit yeah so we're
collecting things like every time they
hit a key every time they evaluate a
cell every time they click on a button
we're collecting a little piece of data
that tells us a timestamp and the
contextual information about what they
were doing so I'm going to I'm going to
walk through some really simple kind of
what data were collecting stuff and some
simple statistics and then I'm gonna
have a colleague take over and show some
very very cool style what he's doing
with the data analysis so things that
were collecting we are collecting
keystrokes so there's a timestamp
there's the actual key that they pressed
there's the cell that they pressed it in
we also have a uuid for the particular
cell and the session time so I have this
nice giant data set and it's something
like yeah 13,000 data points for a
pretty small project that a student did
some really simple basic things we can
immediately start to see is when as a
student working so they clearly this is
a character code so this is a
representation of them pressing a
particular key and then this is a real
time along the horizontal axis so we can
see oh man they were definitely awake
and working at that moment if we zoom in
a little bit further on the timeline
then you can start to look at how they
were how they were typos whoa that is
that is the responsive notebook image
all right Oh aggressively yeah so real
time again and character code up here
this is within just a short hour long
period and you can start to see you know
when when were they able to code when
were they just reading maybe they were
just reading the teachers text maybe
they were coding a little bit stopping
and then coding some more where were
they typing in what type of cells so I
am really big on the writing component
but they do end up coding a lot so this
person you know wrote a lot of stuff
inside of an input cell which is their
code so they were typing a lot inside of
there and I really push them to do
bulleted lists I'm very excited that
this student did so many bullet it lists
that they kind of immediately shot up on
their character count what were they
typing where is another question so this
is inside of input cells which
characters were they typing these are
very basic statistical things we're
going to grow and grow and grow the one
I can point to one piece of evidence
which is they were using close square
bracket a lot when they were coding so
this is actually them coding something
useful I would like to see some more at
science up there I'm gonna push maybe
some ampersand some day but ok so
another little piece of data is
evaluations I say a little piece of data
but I mean a credible amount of data
there's I wonder if this is not going to
click for me all right so for every oh
here's a small example for every time
stamp when they hit shift enter we get
the Box data for whatever they evaluate
it at that moment so as a student starts
to program we start to see everything
that
actually evaluated being able to see
what they evaluate it win is to me sort
of a fundamental piece of information so
over here this is code that they wrote
themselves and this is code that they
got from the notebook that i gave them
they wrote ten times more they evaluate
it ten times more things than the stuff
that I gave them that's a cool number
you can see a little date histogram of
evaluations so you can figure out when
they were really coding if we are doing
automated assessment i would get 12
pieces of code from the student because
i'm collecting evaluations i have 436
pieces of code from the student and yeah
i'm not going to visually inspect these
but i have mechanisms to do data
analysis to figure out what the heck
they were coding and why so that's this
huge loss of information when you start
doing automated code analysis and
ignoring what a student was doing while
they were trying to get to their
solution so every expression inside of
Mathematica can be represented as a
tree-like plot x from 0 to 1 so if you
look at the evaluation of a tree and
this is kind of where we stripped out a
lot of information from this just for a
kind of visual talking points you can
see once they get over to step 5 they
started adding a lot of options or they
copied and pasted a lot of stuff into a
function so you start to get these
little extra branches and then they cut
them out and then they moved along and
then they got to 11 to 12 and because
I've peaked at the code I understand
what happened between 11 and 12 and I
could definitely have an algorithm tell
me this graph has just completely
shifted and you should see what the
student did they used the function with
which is a very advanced programming
technique in my opinion for somebody
who's never coded before they needed to
control the evaluation of some variables
and then plug it into something else and
have it then evaluate that thing so to
me this was a great learning moment that
I'm able to discover
what they were trying to program was
this very nice visualization of you know
probability distributions and yeah yeah
okay so I'm going to skip some slides
that you will have time so now i'm just
going to probably show things and say
words very quickly but we can ask things
like wind where mistakes happening so we
can look at whether the evaluations had
good syntax or bad syntax where were
they using new symbols so I like this
graph a lot this is the accumulation of
new symbols in their evaluations over
time so of course they start the module
and they start running the first piece
of code and they have you know maybe
eight pieces of unique Wolfram language
symbols in there as they work through
the notebook they you know accumulate up
to about 120 unique symbols that they've
learned and used inside of a piece of
code skip down this is about the size of
the code that they're evaluating so as
the student progresses through the
module their writing bigger and bigger
pieces of code oh yeah so when when you
mark up your notebook and you say this
is the solution to that problem that I
want the student to see they don't just
see a giant piece of you know stuff they
get step-by-step walkthrough whatever
your solution was so as they see a step
they're forced to give feedback about
whether they're confused or happy or
upset and we're collecting that piece of
data so every step they see they say I'm
fine that's fine I understand that oh
wow that's super confusing okay I'm fine
with that piece and you're giving them
step-by-step walkthrough of what they're
seeing so these numbers I'm going to
zoom for a moment these numbers over
here represents the the problem that
they're the solution that they're
looking at
the step that they're looking at and the
rating that they gave it so down here
there's a moment when they got very
confused about something and now I
understand that I should go look at that
something and figure out why they were
confused and see if other students were
also confused oh yeah so i can ask where
were they confused so I you know count
count the of the entire class I look at
which what overlapping steps were they
confused by and I can see okay so
solution 102 step 48 every or four
different students gave me a rating of
three so four different students said
that this step was kind of confusing I'm
going to go in and this is already kind
of built in there so I can click on that
ID and it goes into the author notebook
and pulls out the original piece of code
and I can say oh ok they were confused
by this piece of code I should maybe
edit that for the next time I hand out
this module I am all about trying to
improve my teaching based on student
feedback I really like that feedback
loop so I'm very no I'm going to skip
the very basic I'll mention these things
super cursory more key presses do not
seem to correspond to a better score so
if you're coding and you're pressing a
lot of keys that doesn't necessarily
mean that you're going to get a better
score there is a slight correlation
between more key presses while you're
writing and your score but that is
probably because the way that I grade I
like students who fill out really nice
descriptions of what they're doing so
the written portion i do grade heavily
so maybe that's just me kind of seeing
my own grading style there is some
fancier data analysis stuff that's in
the future we'd like to be able to do
automated assessment so well you're kind
of typing and you're trying to solve
something you get to a point and you
start to wander along this graph and you
move towards either a procedural
solution or an incorrect solution that's
very common
or maybe a nice functional solution and
as the students programming progresses
along these two axes you can say hey you
might want to start using map rather
than table so that you can get towards
the functional solution but this is down
the road and we'll talk right now about
some very early results well thanks
thanks Collins is on is hearing I think
I'm just going to erase the word
advanced and just go with data analysis
because Kyle right likes to put the bar
pretty high but we'll see what we get to
by the end of this talk so we had a talk
right before about graph analysis and we
have all this data right it would be
uncharacteristic of a data analysis talk
to not include a graph so this is
actually using I graph which the
previous speaker was talking into
package very cool package um so this is
data set and it's only 34 students
actually that we have data for but
instead of making each node a student
and have them connect between you know
the time that they were evaluating that
Kyle showed that piece of information
instead we're making we're bending all
their time stamps in about five minutes
lots and then we're asking where there
more than one student working at the
same time because we want to be able to
identify sort of clusters of study
habits or times if it as soon as I've
been working and we get the sort of
beast of a graph theory and then of a
graph and we can try and do some more
clustering algorithms to find if indeed
we had communities of students and how
they work so this particular choice of
algorithm that and this is a choice you
can choose to cater it to your needs
highlight it ten different communities
so again nodes are timestamps so times
in which they were working and then
they're connected with an edge if there
were more than one student working on at
the same time but then we can go in and
sort of dig deeper and figure out what
those times exactly were with relation
to sort of real time or so the gray
areas here the weekends Green is where
we had lecture time and then blue is the
office hours and we can sort of scroll
between the numbers to highlight certain
groups of students that let me see if I
remember which one is the so this guy's
sort of start panicking right before the
assigned
assessments do during the weekend and
start coding heavily I call those
typical MIT procrastinators my professor
Craig called them local time optimizers
let's see and there's other stuffs
people that sort of more diligently work
throughout this is very this is sort of
data gathered by only one assessment on
34 students but sort of this is the sort
of things that we can start doing with
the data that we have we can then take
those students now invert it instead of
nodes big time style you can have nodes
be students and sort of cluster them
you're using a dendrogram that sort of
stephen showed a couple days ago and the
sort of the vertical distance here
horizontal distance means nothing and
then the vertical distance sort of shows
how close each students are then we can
go in and ask where they're sort of
central students in these groups of
clusters that sort of so there's a lot
of questions to be asked and that's why
I'm using data analysis not advance
because I have we haven't had the time
to sort of dig into the data but we have
a lot of it and then we should have
started this machine learning and
there's a lot of talk to a machine
learning happening in this conference so
there's a very simple model you see the
data set that we used has 13 features
and with only 34 examples if anyone's
ever used machine learning they will
quickly tell you it's crazy over fitting
and it is von Neumann said with four
parameters I can fit an elephant with
five I can make his trunk wiggle or
whatever he said so this is crazy
overfitting but the point that we're
getting to is that we're not using
machine learning to predict that's my
next slide we're sort of using it to go
in and figure something out about those
features so some of the features are the
total number of valuations each row is
an example student so there's 34 and the
features are self coding is just a ratio
with how much code day road versus the
code total code which is code de Road
plus code that was supplied by the
teacher total time in seconds I worked
on it bats in tax the leaf counting the
code depth which is some features about
code complexity text to code this is the
number that I think Kyle bases his score
exclusively on he finds the highest
number and gives
gives those people are hundreds average
reading and all that and then there's
something that I was interested in
fraction coded in lecture so this finds
the times that they were coding based on
time stamps that they were actively in
lecture or in office hours I'm sort of
trying to answer am I really needed in
this class I'm teaching a system for the
class so we can run this model and it
gets a confusion matrix which is pretty
poorly performing it's about fifty
percent which I would argue for thirty
four examples it's all that bad but and
we will have upwards to 200 and 500
examples by the end of the semester but
the more importantly thing to note is
that it doesn't matter that it's fifty
percent we want something that's
accurate enough so then we can go in and
splunk the feature space and what we're
doing it's an interesting algorithm let
me see if I can show it so we have these
features and here I'm showing a dummy
data set that has three random colors
three random numbers and three random
words and the idea is a [ __ ] row is a
student an example and NH each column is
a data set if I take say column for here
and I start shuffling it oops
essentially what I'm doing is I'm I'm d
associating for each of the row the
feature associated without column with
the entire of the space so if I'm then
passing this row into this algorithm if
you know column number four was a very
important element for the algorithm to
be able to identify and cluster
performance if it's missing that
information or if it's confused because
it got shuffled then its accuracy is
inevitably going to drop and we know
it's going to drop the question is then
the largest rope is sort of an indicator
of how important that variable is and
you run this on the data set and we get
so there's two ways of doing it you can
either just completely remove all the
elements by missing them or shuffle them
as well I was showing and you get stuff
like that and sort of says that text to
code is very important again validation
to Kyle sort of grading scheme and the
self coding if they stick to what we
give them they don't perform as well so
these are important but what I'm really
interested in and this is the shuffling
so it
make what I'm really interested in his
interdependencies so what if instead I
take one column and I shuffle it all
right miss it I take pears and I start
doing you know the permutations of all
features and then I you know either
delete those with missing values or I
shuffle them and then I rerun my
accuracy test the accuracy is going to
drop again but then depending on how it
drops we can sort of start looking at
interdependencies between the variables
that we chose because if it could
perform well with one but not both of
them then sort of that sort of proves or
to some extent shows that they're
interdependent and there's proof of
concept algorithms examples for that but
what I wanted to highlight last night
sort of an aha moment that we had was
you look at this matrix plot and then
you go in and you fine ok so there's
this point 29 so there's a you know 71
percent reduction in accuracy when you
have fraction of coded and lecture and
average coding speed so that's an
interesting joven example I think what's
happening is that they're coming to
office hours and I'm taking her laptop
sort of actively trying to code and then
there I coding speed goes up the same if
I do so this is sort of an artifact but
the fact that the algorithm a priori
highlights our artifact of the way the
data is structured is very encouraging
and moving forward we could do the same
with the list wise in three dimensions
and again we have this cross where
people that do come to office hours that
are coding speed goes up at least
presumably and also their built-in
dictionary because they're like oh yeah
I wanted to do this and like yeah of
course you could do this this function
Mathematica does it for you so people
that come to office hours have their
dictionary shoot up have their coding
speed shut up so I think what we're
trying to show here and if you want to
finish kyle is that there's a an insane
amount of data that we're collecting
sounds good there's an insane amount of
data and we've only just begun
scratching the surface of what we can do
with it yeah that's it thank you
you
[Applause]